it's hard to believe that Queen Mia has
been ruling over Genovia for the last 15
years when we last saw her she was
trying to stay true to herself while
respecting her people which wasn't an
easy thing to accomplish now that the
three quilt is underway fans are curious
to find out what the movie has in store
for them watch until the end to find out
which family member is rumoured to be
taking over the throne come Princess
Diaries three shut up same cast Anne
Hathaway has managed to make a name for
herself outside of the Princess Diaries
franchise she has gone on to become an
oscar-winning actress whose reputation
precedes her but she's not above
reprising her old role as Mia
Thermopolis in January of 2019 and
talked about the upcoming threequel
while on the set of watch what happens
live she confirmed that Julie Andrews
who plays Mia's royal grandmother and
producer Deborah Martin Chase are eager
to reprise their roles however an also
mentioned that they don't want to do a
three quelle unless it's perfect
luckily for us and is full of ideas and
already knows how she wants me a story
to end so far we know that Ian and Julie
are in and we also know that Mandy Moore
and Chris Pine are also interested this
comes as a relief because fans couldn't
imagine Princess Diaries 3 without the
wicked Lana Thomas and the charming
Nicholas Devereaux still fans are
worried that some classic characters
aren't going to make an appearance so
who do we need to see in the three quo
well there's Joe of course but we'd also
like to see Heather Matarazzo
and Robert Schwartzman reprised their
roles of lily and Michael Moskovitz
respectively we're also dying to find
out what happened to fat Louie while
it'd be close to impossible for Louie to
be alive and well
Mia might be caring for one of his
descendants or a similar-looking house
cat and lest we forget Mia's mother
Helen who is played by Caroline Goodall
so the future of your country is in the
hands of my 15 year old without these
means the newest installment to the
Princess Diaries franchise just wouldn't
be the same who else do you want to see
in the movie let us know in the comments
Clarice and Joe although the Princess
Diaries franchise is primarily focused
on Mia's coming-of-age and romantic
relationships there's another
love story that definitely steals the
show yes
we're talking about Clarisse Renaldi and
Joe's secret love affair at first
Clarisse comes off as super strict and
unforgiving but soon we find out that
she's harboring a sweet and flirty side
which she only shows to her bodyguard
Joseph their budding relationship is a
constant reminder that love knows no age
limit from longing looks too spontaneous
dances to a surprise engagement it's
clear that Joe and Clarisse are a match
made in heaven fans want to see these
two amazing characters together again
and they won't settle for anything less
it's been confirmed by the Princess
Diaries author Meg Cabot that the three
cool script already exists however Anne
Hathaway's rep reportedly told BuzzFeed
that the script is way too premature to
discuss so we're hoping that Joe and
Clarisse will make an appearance in the
three quill and remind us what true love
really looks like things just wouldn't
be the same without the power couple
keep watching to find out which royal
family member is said to be taking over
the genovian throne New York City it
goes without saying that the Princess
Diaries novel and movies have their fair
share of differences in fact Mia lives
in Manhattan in the novel's whereas she
resides in San Francisco in the movies
although a good portion of the movies
takes place in Genovia we're used to
seeing Mia as a city girl fans can't
imagine Princess Diaries 3 solely
happening in Genovia which is why we
need to see Mia and her royal family
visiting her hometown we can only assume
that Mia visits her mother stepfather
and little brother from time to time and
if she has kids of her own she'd
definitely want them to see where she
grew up well according to the late Gary
Marshall who directed the first two
movies it looks like they want to do The
Princess Diaries in Manhattan the late
director passed away in 2016 just months
after interviewing with People magazine
it was here that Gary confirmed that the
project was a go and that it would take
place in New York since the three quo
will serve as a tribute to Gary's memory
we can only suspect that they'll honor
his original idea but what would Queen
Mia be doing in New York school reunion
there are many reasons why the Queen of
Genovia would visit man
New York but for the most part we think
that she'll be visiting her family
perhaps Helen Patrick and Trevor will
have moved to Manhattan and me and her
family will be passing by for a visit if
there's one thing fans need to see in
Princess Diaries 3 its Queen Mia and
Lana Thomas meeting face to face after
all these years so we're hoping that a
high school reunion will be in the works
this would allow us to see what all of
our favourite characters have been up to
since we last left off in 2004 fans are
curious to find out if Liana is still
the classic mean girl she was in high
school however during an interview with
Elle magazine Mandy Moore expressed her
great disdain towards her character she
told Elle if I'm going to be involved I
would be down for a cameo
maybe Lana could make amends with Mia
and apologize for being a bully when she
was younger
are you really speaking at the bulimic
convention so you can speak but while
this would be nice we sort of wanna see
Lana and mia face off in the three quill
did Lana grow up to become a kind and
successful woman or did she turn out to
be a cruel soccer mom with a hidden
agenda
no matter the case we'd love to see a
high school reunion in the works do you
guys think Lana has what it takes to
apologize for her past behavior sound
off in the comments section Mia and
Michael okay let's cut to the chase boo
did Queen Mia take us her husband
although she made it abundantly clear
that she didn't eat a husband rule over
Genovia that doesn't mean she stopped
dating altogether although many of us
were rooting for Nicholas by the end of
Princess Diaries to something else can't
help but think that Michael is the
obvious choice after all Mia and Michael
do end up together in Meg Cabot's novels
so there's a very good chance that we'll
see Michael sitting on the genovian
throne next to Mia whether Michael and
Mia end up together or not doesn't
change the fact that fans want to see
actor Robert Schwartzman reprised his
role as Moskovitz sibling in fact after
finding out that Mia and Michael end up
together in the book series Robert told
glamour that he'd be open to appearing
in the three quill we don't know about
you but we loved the idea of Lily being
Mia's sister-in-law how amazing would
that be in the end Michael did make
Mia's foot pop during their first kiss
so he must be the one right
Mia and Nicolas wrong according to some
diehard Princess Diaries fans Nicholas
Devereaux is the only way to go not only
is Nicolas accustomed to the royal life
but he's an honest man who cares about
the people of Genovia
I refuse to be king ladies and gentlemen
it is princess Mia who should have the
crown he would be an amazing king who
knows how to cater to his people
despite being raised by the evil
Viscount Mabrey Nicholas was able to
stay true to himself and do the right
thing he went against his uncle to
support me as claim to the throne and
helped her become a kingless queen now
if that isn't true love we don't know
what is on top of that it's clear that
me and Nicholas have a connection and
it's bound after own since Mia's
coronation we mean who could forget me
as flirtatious wing Nicholas and Mia
would surely be a power couple bounded
by a strong set of morals although
Michael would be all of these things and
more
we just can't imagine him giving up his
normal life to serve as a genovian royal
in 2004 Chris Pine was far from being
the successful actor he is today
so his fans would definitely jump at the
chance to see him in the three quill
Chris has confirmed that he's interested
in portraying the charming Nicholas
Devereaux out once again however we've
yet to see his name on the casting list
so don't hold your breath
so are you guys team Michael or team
Nicholas let us know in the comments
kids whether Mia ends up with Nicholas
or Michael is up to her but there is
something fans are holding out for they
want to see Queen Mia's children in
Princess Diaries three and they might
just get what they want it's been 15
years since Princess Diaries royal
engagement came out in theaters so it's
safe to assume that me and her husband
might have some kids of their own since
the series is called Princess Diaries
fans expect to meet Mia's daughter as
she starts training one day to take over
the genovian throne and since Mia's
makeover was such a success better much
better we'd like to see her children get
the same royal treatment
if Mia's firstborn is a girl she'll be
around 14 years old which is slightly
younger than Mia was when we first met
her coincidentally her eyebrows will
probably remain untouched seeing as
trends have changed and bushy eyebrows
are
now in style will grandma Clarisse be
the one to instruct her grandchildren on
how to act like a royal or will they be
tasked with acting like normal kids
while visiting grandma Helen in New York
we think that Mia and her husband will
have two children the firstborn being a
girl in the second born being a boy what
are your predictions Lilly and Jeremiah
Princess Diaries three just wouldn't be
the same without me as partner-in-crime
Lilly Lilly and Mia we're best friends
before Mia found out that she was
royalty and their relationship never
changed even after things didn't work
out between me and Lilly's brother their
friendship is one of a kind which is why
we need to see Mia and Lilly hanging out
after all these years we'd love to find
out if these besties have children of
similar ages and whether or not they're
as close as their mothers are it would
also be amazing to find out that Lilly
and Jeremiah went from friends to lovers
and although Jeremiah sports a very
different look these days all it would
take is some red-haired ID to get him
back into his old groove we can only
hope that Mia's children get to spend
time with Lilly's family every single
summer want to be normal
Mia was against the idea of taking over
the genovian crown at first however she
eventually chose to honor her bloodline
and became the first English Queen
Genovia had ever seen I believe I will
be a great Queen however Mia is living
proof that we don't need to follow in
our parents footsteps so it's possible
that our children will want nothing to
do with the crown in fact we might see
them trying to blend in to a New York
landscape while attempting to reinvent
themselves there's nothing wrong with
wanting a normal life and Queen Mia
knows that all too well so if her kids
want to abdicate the crown she'll
probably be tasked with finding a new
successor and believe it or not Trevor
will allegedly rise up to the occasion
Trevor and Letitia shockingly enough
Mia's little brother Trevor Thermopolis
O'Connell will allegedly be tasked with
taking over the genovian throne this
comes as a surprise since Trevor isn't
related to the royal bloodline but
according to an IMDB synopsis Trevor
will be recruited by Jo and trained to
become a proper Prince and since Trevor
will be known as a bad boy
clarice and Joe will have their work cut
out for them this synopsis also states
that Trevor will be 16 years old
throughout the movie and they'll be made
to battle against me as snooty cousins
before being pegged as King material
actress Ally Murray who is said to be
playing Spanish princess Letitia Maria
Stella is set to play Trevor's arranged
bride however whether any of this is
true has yet to be confirmed by the
original cast so we're choosing to view
this synopsis as a fan-made theory for
the time being regardless we'd love to
see me as little brother pop up on the
big screen so what do you absolutely
want to see in Princess Diaries 3 let us
know in the comments section below
thanks for tuning in to the things if
you're as excited as we are about
Princess Diaries 3 make sure to give
this video a big thumbs up wanna be the
first to find out about Mia's upcoming
adventures then don't forget to hit that
subscribe button we'll catch you next
time
[Music]